to students and staff she was a black
professor
there continues to be a class-based and
political tension
her media bio called her an unrepentant
and unreformed
child of the hood so i will end there
thank you for listening but now jessica
krug has revealed
she lied she is in fact white and from
kansas city
the associate professor at george
washington university
had claimed african and latina heritage
her confession online
was a shock on campus it's honestly
disgraceful because she built a lot of
personal relationships with students
a lot one student was saying that they
talked to her outside of class she
helped them through their personal
emotional like stuff so to know that all
of that was a lie and she was
telling people to embrace their identity
some people make mistakes that's all
that's all that happens i don't
necessarily felt betrayed but i just
mean like kind of blatant disrespect for
the people who are going through a lot
of stuff that we're seeing currently in
the states
the academic had reportedly used an
activist pseudonym
jessica la bombalera in her confession
blog online
she said her deception was rooted in
mental health issues as a child
she wrote i have built my life on a
violent anti-black lie
and i have lied in every breath i have
taken i am not a culture vulture
i am a culture leech i actually don't
like the term african-american i prefer
black
the case bears a strong similarity to
one five years ago
of rachel dolazal a white race activist
she grew up white then claimed to be
black
until she was outed by her parents
[Applause]
amidst this country's current reckoning
on race relations
the deception of a high-profile academic
has been met with shock
she claimed this particular kind of like
working class black identity a fake
version of that a stereotypical version
of that
in order to gain clout in order to gain
access
to spaces and resources including
scholarships
fellowships grants um and um
including her job in a statement george
washington university has said it's
aware of its professor's blog post
and is looking into the situation a
university study
in career deception james matthews sky
news
washington